le système de retraite français un
acquis social depuis 1945 auquel il est
bien difficile de s'attaquer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
premier exemple en 1981 inquiet du
vieillissement croissant de la
population et de ses conséquences sur
l'équilibré du système de retraites le
premier ministre michel rocard avait des
idées dont celle ci afin de préserver le
système par répartition dans lequel les
actifs paient pour les retraites des
inactifs
il faut selon michel rocard
progressivement adapter le système
première variable que l'on peut modifier
le temps de cotisation l'âge de départ à
la retraite était alors fixée à 60 la
proposition du premier ministre ne
faisait donc pas vraiment l'unanimité
auprès des syndicats il est question
dangereusement de remettre en cause
l'accès à la retraite à 60 ans l'idée de
michel rocard aboutira avec son
successeur edouard balladur en 1993 mais
uniquement pour le secteur privé alors
deux ans plus tard en 1995 le premier
ministre alain juppé y pense aussi pour
la fonction publique et les régimes
spéciaux il normal que les 1 go 10 40
ans les eaux 37 ans et demi
réponse immédiate des syndicats de
fonctionnaires mobilisés dans toute la
france on a signé un contrat quand on
est entré dans la fonction publique pour
travailler 37 ans et demi il ya aucune
raison que gouvernement nous trop pas
changé un contrat maintenant la forte
mobilisation de 95 fera finalement
renoncé le gouvernement mais huit ans
plus tard en 2003 autre tentative du
premier ministre jean pierre raffarin sa
nouvelle réforme des retraites vise
encore une fois le secteur public
elle est alors défendu par son ministre
des affaires sociales françois fillon
alors on augmentera progressivement la
durée de cotisation pour passer à 41 ans
en 2012
là encore l'idée a du mal à passer
auprès des syndicats de fonctionnaires
[Applaudissements]
malgré les contestations le texte de
jean pierre raffarin est votée quatre
ans plus tard en 2007
la nouvelle réforme du président sarkozy
prévoyait aussi un allongement de la
durée de cotisation mais pour les
régimes spéciaux
les syndicats de cheminots montait au
créneau maintenant on va me dire alors
que je côté depuis 31 ans plus que tout
le monde on va me dire que j'ai le plus
loin non il n'est pas question cette
fois ci le gouvernement ne céda pas mais
à cordes à des compensations aux
cheminots en 2010 nouvelle réforme des
retraites sous la présidence sarkozy et
les manifestations étaient encore
massive
cette année-là l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite est définitivement repoussé
à 62 ans
aujourd'hui l'histoire se répète pour et
loire philippe dans les cortèges
des dizaines de milliers de français
disent non à sa nouvelle réforme des
retraites
[Musique]